hello code a show where we talk about
the show that talks about the movie I'm
specifically Errol hello Danny ready
ready go that turn to untangle ahead all
right saved um today we're speaking
about the film hook hmm I feel like
we're gonna ruffle some feathers with
this one yeah let's sit on this trailer
with what I'm about to say right now and
like hook that much it's not that good
man I love this kid watch it again not
as good did not hold up to coin a phrase
from span I did equipment very long it's
off-putting in many places now I love
this movie when I saw it in theaters
this is a little baby boy real tears
flowing when Rufio died just remember
just being really captivated by the Lost
Boys and their like problem really have
enjoys and Dustin Hoffman but and you go
back and I'm like this is the opposite
of what I want to see Robin Williams do
I wish it was someone who is known for
the opposite of him that got to finally
you know show some joy in the last 20
minutes instead of Robin Williams who's
like a cartoon character being like a
dick for so long and then he finally
lets loose at the end you can tell they
cast him like we're doing a thing where
Peter Pan is an adult and they're just
like Robin Williams and there was like
perfect
it was got a boy who's a man that's
perfect and then they neglected that to
note that 80% of the movie is him being
a dour depressed neurotic neurotic it's
like I don't hey Christopher Walken but
we all know how that turned out with
with his look it's it's me yeah it's bad
Hanks mmm I mean he could have pulled it
off but yeah I'm trying it's not easy I
have to go back to the early 90s
yeah to
whom it could be it had to be like an
everyman type in the early 90s Tim al
Russell who should have been the scores
great John Williams the beautiful very
clearly on a soundstage or in front of a
matte painting but that's better than
like a weird CGI thing it's still you're
like they put a lot of work in all this
Dustin Hoffman is great he's jounin he's
awesome yeah Hoskins is Kyle Hoskins is
great
Rufio is the [ __ ] yeah kids are good
well yeah the kids are good jack is good
the some of the Lost Boys are like
pushing the boy super old
I like that somehow The Lost Boys got
extreme as we entered the 90s with like
the sick half pie we were all well but
how did the Lost Boys I don't know
well they cause if they when the Lost
Boys aged Peter Pan kills them this is a
new crop got it okay cool
that makes sense I thought they they
thought that it would probably heighten
the stakes if Peter had two children and
so they're like there's his son who is
gonna be kind of enticed by Captain Hook
and it's gonna be this whole thing of
Peter and his son and their whole
relationship and his daughter who's
there because they she I mean I I didn't
take count I swear she disappears for 45
minutes of the movie we're like Jack and
Captain Hook are doing all the things
well cuz she's not buying it man she's
not buying it so she's an idiot she gets
disappeared for like 40 minutes of the
film yeah that didn't she didn't need to
exist I guess you're right now but it's
it raises the stakes and then you have a
cute little girl doing a song in the
middle of
yeah which is from it was music there
was gonna be a musical huh I believe
that John Williams was helping write
music for I like the song
I love the baseball game scene yeah Jack
yeah when they shoot the guy and
everyone laughs played for comedy
there's a lot of that oh yeah lots of
death
lots of delight if you thought Pirates
of the Caribbean was like are we good
with these weird like pirates being like
gee like oh these Pirates are real
pirates just fun fun times are shootin
people for sillies pirates but at the
same time like Peter kills a lot of them
yes a lot of there's a lot of death
dying and if you'd like I do assume that
the colored goop is poison The Lost Boys
murder a shitload yeah that stuff's
poison that's acid yeah those kids would
have survived this long of that stuff
was not weaponized chemical weapon
darker than you think
let's take a look yeah at the Australian
[Music]
she knew the booth horses said they did
every 90s kid wondering what if
Tinkerbell was a sad middle-aged Peter
Pan back in every land I can see why you
have trouble finding a happy thought so
many sad memories oh the scripture said
crows sadly least favorite Spielberg
movie I want to see hook again because I
still don't like that movie even though
it's the boss he's just kind of maybe
just cuz I just watched glow but he
really sounds like Marc Maron someday
yeah I me and jaws cool are we cool I
love my cat thumper just got sleep back
yeah yeah what the hook what the hook
and ears
what the Hogan ops I think that's the
thing with hook was the concept of it
sounded like a slam dunk it's like
Steven Spielberg the master of boyhood
wonder Robin Williams a child trapped in
a man's body in a story about a grown-up
Peter Pan I was like yes yes yes and
then you look back and you're like oh no
no no well it had all the right elements
but it something's not something didn't
fire quite right I'll talk about my
thing with this being a weird Spielberg
movie in a couple of sections it becomes
a little more valid I also apologize I
got yelled at this morning because I
pound the desk when I talk I apologize
oh yeah you
I get animated I'm sorry it's apparently
very annoying okay I'm not annoyed I'm
just like wow you're he's really he's
literally pounding the best I can I get
excited but I apologize for the audio
files at home apparently it's causing
some audio issues so judged and like
yeah nevermind let's keep going because
I still don't like that movie even
though it's the best film in the entire
Peter pantheon where by best we mean
least racist
[Music]
most memorable Indians mentioned in this
movie but it's never seen continuous
coverage a smells like teen spirit
some day pants crazy pants there's no
reason for it to exist one because no
one ever asked for like a weird gritty
but also really like psychedelically
bizarre reboot it's because own origin
this is like not Creative Commons but
it's like anyone can use oh yeah yeah
you can jump into a Peter Pan as many
times you want you have ya but ya know
it's nuts there is no reason for the
song no reason they lean into it's not a
cheap song to Lysa no no so they there's
one line in the movie where someone
suggests that Neverland is a nexus for
like all-time lines so like oh so
Nirvana stole their song from fire or
like or someone who entered Neverland
from like our time just thought someone
came in from pirate times that notorious
sea shanty but then the movie doesn't do
anything with that yeah they're like oh
yeah it's the Nexus of all timelines
whatever and like they're they're mining
and pixie dust is like unobtainium and
they're like remaining it it's so crazy
and they try to fix the Indians by like
being like well it's all cultures and
they're just nutty hippies that would so
be sold to Netflix if it was coming out
today yeah that Mowgli Mowgli and panel
Mowgli did go to Netflix that's what I
mean yeah like no and one that Netflix
just bought because they're okay it's a
watch find out why that's in there but
today is not the day meet Peter banning
professionals cellphone never
[Applause]
he is Robin Williams like you've never
wanted to see him before grumpy and
completely shaved from head to toe bus
this is my it was weird cuz it didn't
strike me at first I saw this shot and I
was like something's figure out what's
weird I was like what is weird about
this and then I realized like accent
coming out of simon Pegg's yeah Robin
Williams was notoriously one of the
hairiest men arriving there yeah that
was like a bit for him yea yeah you know
every cop special he did he was talking
about how hairy he was shaved him down
I'll shave is there maybe it's just the
lighting and a little bit of makeup but
does he have like the beginnings of a
Marvel AB oh yeah it might be sort of
airbrushed but like this could be the
first Marvel AB yeah yeah they shaved
and down like a like a laboratory monkey
very off-putting and strange right there
putting makeup on him this is I guess
this is my version of simon Pegg's
american accent in the uncanny valley
for me it looks like they put his head
on someone else's Bob it does it's like
a Captain America thing yeah yeah and
they cut this thing where the Lost Boys
went off over chest there's kids get
taken off to Neverland Peter Benning
will have to become Peter Pan again at
the 100 minute mark of a 140 minutes
movie how was I that patient as a kid
enter a spellbinding version of our own
world where the Peter Pan stories are
all fiction a stick a panty the movie
ends really strong except they're not
because their own based on historical
events the stories are true
except for that one shot where they
imply that everything was all a dream
the hell was that okay boss this there's
something weird going on with Smee this
didn't make it into the the trailer
there there is a a part of the movie
where Smee produces for Captain Hook
Peter Pan's dental records
yeah medical mysteries Peter banning is
medical
so is Smee like because they it they
imply that there's like a spot so is me
like a spy that's what I always if he
infiltrate a doctor's office and like
like Richard Kimble it with like a badge
and everything and rifle through the
files and bridges should be in the movie
yes that would be over in the other
world sneaking into a dentist's office
is that but is that but to me I thought
that it was just from an earlier draft
of the script and they were like they
wanted to throw in a head-fake of like
but it could all be in his head but
that's how they played that cuz there's
no like if they were trying to say with
Smee there would have been a little wink
and a nod but there's not that it was
like did he just get out like everything
was going to hell so he escaped and now
he's a janitor I don't because that's
not the only time they do it because
Hoffman is the pilot that comes over the
PA oh yeah in the plane what yeah baby
they Wizard of Oz the hell out of this
thing a couple of times and it's so why
I don't know it's I think it was a
leftover draft yeah well this is like
prequel to pan we're like there's
crossing timelines
yeah and Smee is like hannover it's like
quantum leaping his way through every
Peter Pan remake which I would also
watch starring Bob Hoskins I would have
loved if he's ripped off his beard just
like Luigi gotta go keep going and if
that's not confusing enough enjoy a
family dynamic where Wendy has always
had a crush on Peter
I hacked it but then she adopted him as
her own grandson after he kissed her
granddaughter on the lips while she
slept
and she still clearly has the hots for
him grandma that is so bang wrong don't
lean in near openness and good morning
to the saddest place you can imagine
Neverland a prison island in a state of
perpetual war infested by a pirate army
that's suicidally depressed try to stop
me Smee okay yikes but there's also the
Lost Boys a tribe of tweenage murderers
who are probably starving to death on
imaginary hay and can't hide the fact
that after an eternity of battle they're
all broken children desperate for some
structure and guidance do you remember
your father Peter
okay how do I think this movie was fun
when I was a kid was like that blinded
by Rubio's half-shirt in triple hawk
yeah so this is my thing with Steven
Spielberg at this movie is that
Spielberg is always so good at being
like here's how I want you to feel
here's what I think you know here's what
my movies trying to say there's the
music that makes you sad here's the
scene that makes you sad here's the shot
that makes you sad or uplifted or
whatever I have no idea from seeing a
scene what he wants to say about
Neverland about Peter Pan because it's
all this weird sex stuff and like Wendy
is this old broken lady and then
everything in Neverland it's terrible
and Neverland makes you forget I mean
that's the source material kind of like
Peter Pan's a dark weird yeah yeah an
eternal child dude kidnaps other
children I've never actually have you
read Peter and Wendy not the first no
not like the damn Barry book I've never
read it no I I have a theory that it's a
very much Steven Spielberg's own
conflicted feelings cuz this is the
point in his filmography where he's
about to make the pivot to like
Schindler's List in 93 I mean he done
the color purple some serious stuff
before but like he's very like you've
watched Close Encounters of the Third
Kind
Richard Dreyfuss gets in the spaceship
at the end and like he conveniently
doesn't you forget the fact that he just
abandoned his wife but you know if he
did it later than he when he had a wife
and kids and he would leave just like
now I have a wife and kids obviously
that was just that was a really a whole
thing to do so I feel like this movie is
him going like I don't know what I am it
could be a cousin growing I am growing
he sympathized with a man who was losing
his sense of joy and Wonder in the world
and was becoming too much for cynic and
he may be identified with like wine to
remind himself of the childlike joy that
he has to feel in the world but then
there's no joy in the place where he
goes back to fine childlike joy yeah but
he gets it at the end at the end he's
like yeah it's gonna be a really fun
negligent father
I'm unemployed at best now kids
let's go play over 30 you probably have
really fond memories of because you
focus on the incredible Hoffman
performance a million the production
design and your unconditional love for
Robin Williams but when you revisit it
as an adult or were born after 1990
you'll realize it's a sexually charged
violent movie about a midlife crisis
that takes two hours to really get going
but you know for kids yay story
Robin stood in touch double-o the ringer
Maggie Smith as the old lady in Titanic
nothing but respect from My Fire Lord I
can't feel my legs
I Heart Huckabees and random cameos by
this weird when it Paltrow David Cross
had an open set okay this is my favorite
being in the world
we had I know this today minimum of a 15
minute long conversation including
holding photos of Jimmy Buffett up to
the computer screen to decide if this
was actually Jimmy Buffett we decided it
was we're pretty confident that that's
to me but he's listed in IMDB as shoo
stealing pirate have to burp talk Joe
yeah so I mean one puppet with some
pirate makeup on I was at the argument
that Glenn Close does not look like
Glenn Close therefore Buffett doesn't
have to look exactly but he really looks
a lot younger in that photo than he was
in 1991 still away but his face really
looks similar did you text Carlsen we
had to get noe to know well Mike weigh
in if you're if you're watching he
doesn't is that actually Jimmy Buffett
we don't know this we have an absurdly
long yeah
sources say it's Jimmy Buffett we had a
wrong line a couple weeks ago and in a
quiet place okay I just want to double
down I want to make sure we're not
perfect for [ __ ] yeah we're gonna button
up these uh Buffett references yeah
sorry but we weren't willing to pull it
based on the uncertainty we I am I will
put myself at 80 percent confident
that's Jimmy Buffett and I'll take 80
percent confidence I'm 63 percent
confident I'll go all the way to
Margaritaville Jimmy tweet us
[Laughter]
yeah that's great Robert Holtby yeah
look at that
he made that made that the teaser
graphics incredible to that he did is a
reflection of dust is that you show me
the hook just the hook Jake show me the
hook does that have a reflection and it
has a reflection of Dustin ha yeah it's
crazy in there
hope he's amazing Robert Holtby he goes
red hold yeah you know and okay we just
throw this out there but we're Michael
and John toodles
did you kill them I've lost my mom oh
[Laughter]
yeah we kind of came together over
though you're recording with John and I
don't know I think it was right at the
end I think you guys were getting ready
to hang up yeah it was like toodles
killed them yeah it's not the first time
we've been in a trailer like that no a
greatest showman greatest shave an
elephant never forgets that's becoming a
trope I like that beat yeah yeah we've
got the the killer red zoom we've got
the hidden ally do you have a hidden
Ellen I like that yeah the Alan's are
hidden so well there's been a hidden
Alan in every single on his trailer
since Jurassic Park 3 yeah just putting
that out there so for people like there
wasn't an Alan to this one there was
there was I didn't even happy hunting
yeah oh wow I get to be like everyone
else I get to go on a texture icon yeah
you get to be a gun
[Laughter]
yo you you turned them into the biggest
you hate I'm Forrest Forrest gun we got
some deleted scenes let's see yeah see
what cut and she still clearly has the
hots for it
that is so bang wrong Oh easy there
Wendy lady you're gonna have to wait
your turn behind these three mermaids
Tinker Bell and his own wife may pause
if Spielberg is dealing with his own
issues around this time he was was
Australia Peter Pan story personal pain
Oh simple jack a bazooka adapter Robin
side bus oh yeah okay way that was gonna
work was it was gonna be jackie j ck IE
comma robins ro ba an apostrophe s son
it was Jackie Robinson huh yeah and
Robin Williams his son in the movie C
double entendre is not the entendre I
intended when I wrote it but it well
what I wrote I thought no I wrote that
one and I was like you kept it because I
was like that one doesn't work at all
that was like Jack I was like Robin son
cuz Dustin Hoffman's stealing his son
and you're gonna see them side by side
whoa and I thought you misspelled it
that was YX e sometimes I I'm gonna peel
back the curtain for you okay we write a
lot of alts and I respect vomit hold
these time so sometimes I have to make
executive decisions on how many things I
send him and I didn't send him that one
cuz it was spelled ro be bi in and the
script and I was like I don't get that
at all so I didn't I was shocked you
kept it because I was it was like my
fourth one form and I was like yeah
whatever it goes in like oh wow that
works on so many levels cuz he's a
baseball player his name's Jack cuz he's
Robin Williams his son Wow anyway well
there you go keep going
I already have a good man
Eddie violent health in Brockovich we
need marketing power now Julia Roberts
reacting to things that's the Bailey for
improvising real repulsive yeah yeah get
ready Peter man we like that blue one
make more of these the reason you're a
messed up adult now we're just saying
arias childhood trauma these are the
ones that didn't make the whole be cut
yeah hey Jack I apologize it's a very
special watch oh poor kids have to go to
bed at 7:41 time so no wonder they hate
their dad yeah it's a pause so the kids
are tucked into bed at 7:40 assuming he
changes watch when they got to London
but they flew from any town USA I don't
think it's really clear where they came
from so it's it's like either way it's
like Betty em or or 10:00 or 10:30 a.m.
in the morning and he's tucking his kids
there's no way they're gonna sleep no no
for like a day an older man forced back
into a life he doesn't want to save kids
from a villain with a metal hand now
this is my Logan yeah low back Logan
yeah always respectful yeah I feel like
you don't respect Logan enough don't
like it I Logan my Logan yeah I've got
two Logan's in it Logan's Run
yeah that's hook yeah man it if you
don't believe us free watch it for
yourself if you still love it
congratulations get more patients than
we did because I thought that the pacing
was really a slog but there are some
great moments sprinkled throughout so
and that's what you remember it's not
like I haven't watched it since I was a
kid but I felt like I hadn't seen it
before watching it this time just like
you were seeing isn't like what was
really happening on a psychological
level yeah yeah weird very weird movie
yeah yeah that's that tune in next week
where we will be going deeper bluer well
now they know the hats gonna be like a
shark's fin no we're did another purple
thank you Jeff we're gonna keep we do it
all Steven works for MOG Rafi in order
yeah
Sugarland Express here we come sorry
said the first line and then just hold
back yeah keep coming back for more yeah
if you stay around this far you'll be
back next week hooks in yeah goodbye
[Music]
you